It's Monday morning. This is usually my reset day.
I got really shitty sleep last night.
Very tired. I'm very over, um,
leaving my house. I'm gonna cave for the next several days.
But I wanted to pop on here and talk about my last video,
which was basically being kind of surprised
how many people are shocked and offended
by other people celebrating the death of the United Healthcare CEO.
So I wanted to explain my position a little bit further.
I'm not personally celebrating this man's death.
Let's get that out of the way.
I don't think I would ever personally celebrate someone's death.
Hmm. There's a few exceptions.
However, my previous video wasn't about my Celebration.
It's about me understanding why people are celebrating.
And let's be serious for a second.
This is historically accurate.
This has happened before. Right off the top of my head,
I'm thinking the bullshit revolution and the French Revolution.
When you allow greed at the high level of class systems,
whether that be monarchy or,
in this case, capitalism,
when unchecked greed leads to the suffering of a mass populace,
the populace will rise up.
And I grew up around wealthy people,
and I still am afforded a,
like, a really comfortable life.
Okay, I don't wanna live through revolution.
But in order to maintain the status quo,
in order to maintain your position at the top of a social system,
like a class system, um,
you can't just shit all Over everybody.
Constantly over time,
over and over. Because eventually people will have nothing to lose.
And that's where you're seeing the people celebrating
instead of being smart and maintaining a thriving middle class
where people can work for a good wage
and afford the things that they wanna afford,
maybe have some good time off,
maybe a vacation once, twice a year.
The unchecked and unregulated greed of some of these corporations,
and in specifically the healthcare industry,
which directly contributes.
Directly, not like in between.
Middle man directly contributes to the death of people in this country.
The created. They created the monster that's going to eat them,
which is angry people who have suffered for a long time.
Do you hear the people saying,
we have seen this before? Which is why I'm not surprised,
I'm not shocked. This is kind of what I saw coming.
And I think a lot of people have seen this coming.
And I don't think it's over.